great movie critic syndicated columnist
with the Chicago sun-times Richard
Roeper joining us Richard let me start
with the very very difficult question is
it a biopic or biopic I think I think is
what you get when there's some sort of
strange discoloration on your shoulder
blade isn't it so I go with biopic okay
yeah we have Elton John that biopic is
coming out what's the timeframe for that
that's coming out this summer okay it's
starring Taron Egerton people might not
know the name but you've been in the
Kingsmen Secret Circle Circle movies and
a bunch of play the Eagle actually
remember that man gear he actually
played him in a biopic a couple of years
ago did who else is I feel like
Hollywood's gonna go oh my God look at
what Queen made they brought back stars
born are we headed down that road of
more biopics is there a Bob Marley or
David Bowie or Prince biopic everybody
you mentioned there you know there are
films and development there's actually a
bottlee crew biopic that's I think on
Netflix right now I'm still waiting for
ballroom blitz you know the missionary
of the one-hit wonders you know those of
you up for the yep that's Academy
whatever God you know short subjects
best movie you saw this year was one you
know the best movie I saw is a movie
that got no love come nomination I was a
movie called widows which was a heist
movie political thriller set in my
hometown of Chicago directed by Steve
McQueen and won an Oscar for 12 years of
slave
it had Viola Davis and Liam Neeson and
Colin Farrell and Robert Duvall and for
some reason it went one under almost
everyone's radar so if people get a
chance to check out widows that movie
should have won a half-dozen Oscars I
was thrilled that Regina King won but
probably thrilled because of another you
know a different reason than anybody
else
she played Ron tidwell's wife Marcy and
Jerry Maguire that's right and you know
even back then and of course as we know
you know ku-ku-ku-ku Cuba Gooding jr.
won the Academy Award for Best
Supporting Actor
even nominated a lot of people thought
that performance should have been
nominated because when you look back at
that film that's the real relationship
that's more interesting than Tom Cruise
Renee Zellweger it's that wonderful
loving supportive marriage between those
two characters but your brings me to the
topic of Best Supporting and best actor
you know in green book
I couldn't tell as I watched the movie
who would be considered the best actor
and who was the best supporting actor in
there how do you differentiate that or I
mean is this strategically placed of we
have a better chance winning if he's
Best Supporting as opposed to Best Actor
yeah you know the weird thing of the
interesting thing is Dan there are no
you know the Academy has all these other
arcane rules it's like the NFL playbook
there are no rules about what the
supporting or lead performance the
studios can decide
so you mentioned Green Book now I would
say that I think Viggo Mortensen was the
lead because we get his you know we got
about 20 minutes of him at the beginning
of the movie before Herschel Ali's
characters introduced into the film at
that point this cold co-leading stars
but you know for example Olivia Coleman
who won Best Actress last night for the
favorite she's really a supporting
character Emma Stone is the lead in that
movie she's the one who has the most
straight thought so it is strategic in
we think you have a better chance
therefore we get more eyeballs on the
movie if this person wins an Academy
Award and the other thing is Dan just
what kind of an impact it has on
audiences the most famous example is
some he is Anthony Hopkins who won Best
Lead performance for Silence of the
Lambs that movie's over two hours long
he's in the movie for about 20 to 25
minutes but he was so memorable the
studio rightfully thought you know what
let's put him up for lead performance
and he wants the best actor in a film in
which you know Jodie Foster and Scott
Glenn have way more screen time who got
screwed last night well I think in you
know for the best picture I would have
preferred to see black Klansmen or Roma
when I also was not a huge fan of
Bohemian Rhapsody overall and I like you
know Remy Malik's a great actor but he
did not even perform those vocals those
are basically lip-syncing that we saw so
I you know
to me I would have much rather seen
Christian Bale win for vice for lead
actor you had Spike Lee who would tried
to walk out when green look one has that
ever happened before where somebody's
that upset with somebody winning yeah it
has happened a few times although
usually they do it kind of quietly it's
usually it's just people who are upset
that they didn't win you know I know
Will Smith went home early one time they
claimed one of the kids had a cold so I
can't remember anybody walking out you
know Spike Lee it just wanted an Academy
Award you know for a screenplay for for
like lensman but you know he was not
like a lot of people where he was not a
huge fan of Green Book he started to
walk out he came back you know I I don't
know if he thought better of it
I know he had a couple of conversations
with other people's it was don't make
this about you now you know you could
talk about the movie later so but yeah
he was definitely ticked off what's the
2019 movie that we absolutely have to
see I think it's the Irishman which is
the Martin Scorsese film you know it's a
mob film obviously about the you know
the Irish a factor and it's got you know
everybody's back you know some of the
classic says you know we get Gennaro
Pacino Joe Pesci in this movie they've
been talking about the Irishman forever
but now it actually has completed
filming it's really going to happen I
hated The Departed well you know that
there are a lot of mixed feelings about
that you know you're wrong sometimes
this would be one of those cases so I
would suggest you go back and
rewatchable celebrate Nicholson's not
good in that room well you know I will
give you that and you know at a certain
point
Nicholson's career he started just doing
Jack Nicholson you know whose career
would you rather have DeNiro or Pacino
well I you know I think maybe DeNiro
only because you know and I love Pacino
and he's still here he's still churning
out the movies but Gennaro made that
nice pivot where he you know a lot of
fun doing the comedies and also make it
the money because those guys didn't get
paid back in the seventies they didn't
make any money so De Niro I think might
be the more astute businessman and had
as maybe had a little bit more fun
in the you know the homestretch of his
career where are we headed with movies
with the influx of great TV and it feels
like the great actors are going to t be
yeah well you're absolutely right about
that that that's because TV is you know
as least for the last you know half
dozen years maybe longer been more of
the writers medium yet you know as you
know a lot of these movies are superhero
movies that almost write themselves it's
all about the special effects and all of
that whereas something like true
detective and Handmaid's Tale and a
million others you know these these
episodic shows you know if you're Julia
Roberts you could play the mom of
somebody in a feature film or you can
have the lead in a show like the Amazon
series homecoming where she got to do
you know great work over a you know an
eight or nine Episode arc so I think for
folks like us who you know really
appreciate great writing and great
acting there's probably more of that on
television right now if you will or
streaming whatever you want to call it
that there is the conventional movie
theaters what was the Jennifer Aniston
movie where it's sort of based off Dolly
Parton the the songs that that her
daughter that's a beauty queen yeah yeah
that was actually a lot of fun yeah I
thought it was really well done I
thought that the girl played her
daughter in Anniston I think is
underrated as a comedian dumpling
dumplings the name of it it dumpling
thank you for that yeah well yeah that's
part of the problem there's we can't
think of the title because that's you
know because Netflix is putting out more
movies than all of the studio's put
together and some of them can kind of
get lost in the shuffle but that's
that's a terrific example that movies
not going to get made theaters in 2019
but it was a terrific piece of
entertainment Dolly Parton as you
mentioned contributed you know six
original songs there's a movie that just
came out this weekend of Netflix called
paddle ten yeah with Ray Romano Romano
who again is another guy who like you
know the big sick a couple years ago and
now in this movie proves that he can do
more than sitcom acting so I know a lot
of you know traditional movie you know
critics and studio people are threatened
by Netflix I say you know welcome to the
party because a lot of things that would
never even get produced or released find
a home on Netflix Ray Romano's in the
Irishman
yeah yeah there's a small Rob you know
yeah ton of uh you know familiar comedic
actors you know guys like Scorsese
they've always been great at finding
somebody you know you go all the way
back to the king of comedy where he puts
Jerry Lewis in that role he's always
been great about you know unconventional
casting it's finding something in
someone that we never knew was there
Rupert Pupkin I believe was De Niro so
you go exactly right there
you uh you still haven't reviewed all of
my movies that didn't like my acting
ability you know I well you're you're I
empty your IMDB is you know longer than
John Goodman's at this point so I'd have
to take a week off from all my gigs to
get all the entire Dan Patrick over
although you know we could we could do a
film festival and there you go okay
alright well whose career would you
rather have minor John Goodman's that's
a push it's great to talk to you Richard
hope you're doing well we appreciate you
joining us Richard Roeper Chicago
sun-times nationally syndicated
columnist movie critic yeah I remember
at one point he was he was gonna review
all of my roles in the Sandler movie and
I believe I'm up to like 17 movies
something like that I mean they're not
long scenes but I do they're seen their
movies stealing for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
Direct TV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]